wir kommen an der theresianischen
militärakademie wiener neustadt mein
name ist oberst markus reisen ich bin
der leiter der forschungs und
entwicklungsabteilung und heute wollen
wir uns in einem neuen video ansehen wie
sich die derzeitige situation im donbass
darstellt was wissen wir und was können
wir bereits sagen über den verlauf der
schlacht und in dombach
als erstes kurz eine orientierung was
geschah den letzten wochen in den
letzten wochen war es der fall dass die
russische offensive im norden der
ukraine gescheitert ist und es zu einer
verlagerung der russischen kräfte in den
osten kam hier wurde von russischer
seite ausgedrückt dass das neue ziel der
operationsführung die einkesselung der
ukrainischen streitkräfte im tourbus sei
das heißt das schwergewicht der letzten
wochen war im prinzip die kampf für
unter russische seite hier im ton bass
dem jetzt ono klinischer seite versucht
wieder entgegen zu halten
eine operation kann man in drei phasen
unterteilen die erste phase ist die
sogenannte vorbereitungs oder shaping
face diese vorbereitungsphase hat sich
dadurch ausgedrückt dass die russische
seite versucht hat um die 50 bis 60
tausend soldaten die bereits geschwächt
werden von den kämpfen im raum kiel über
1000 kilometer mit eisenbahnen zu
verlegen in den osten der ukraine und
dort die voraussetzungen zu schaffen wie
der einsatzführung während dies geschah
ende märz anfang april hat man weiteres
versucht zu verhindern dass die
ukrainische seite in vorbereitung auf
diese schlacht kräfte nach führt das
heißt man hat mit luftangriffen versucht
diese versorgungslinien zu unterbrechen
die entscheidende phase hat es dann
knapp mitte april begonnen und das war
der versuch der russischen seite die
kräfte der ukraine an der kontakt linie
ein zug essen es gab hier zwei optionen
eine um fassung in der tiefe an
geländern den täter oder eine
kurzfassung des kristallisiert sich
heraus dass wir in den letzten tagen
diese kurzfassung sehen wo also mit
einer nördlichen zange und kräfte
bereitstellung und einer südlichen
zeitkräfte bereitstellung man versucht
diese ukrainischen kräfte zu umfassen
nun haben wir anfang mai und die
situation ist die dass offensichtlich
dieser russische angriff nicht den
verlauf nimmt den man erwartet hat wir
sehen zwar dass an mehreren stellen der
kurzen umfassung es erfolge der
russischen seite gibt aber
offensichtlich ist ukrainische
widerstand so groß dass es nicht zu
einem durchbruch unter einem vorstoß in
die tiefe kommt und warum das wollen wir
uns jetzt im detail ansehen wenn wir uns
ansehen der russische formel so wahr
kennen wir zwar dass sie gemäß
russischer doktrin vorgehen das heißt
einsatz quasi der kräfte überlegt
abgestimmt dass die verschiedenen
fähigkeiten mit artillerie oder
luftunterstützung aber trotzdem ist es
nicht so dass die russischen kräfte
rasch geländegewinnen das sie brauchen
und dann in die tiefe vorstoßen zu
können wir nehmen nun vier faktoren
anhand derer wir uns die situation
ansehen der erste faktor ist das gelände
selbst wir kennen also hier das im
zentralen raum des kessels an vier
stellen davor was passiert bzw auch
parallel dazu weiter im südwesten ein
vormarsch zumindest begonnen worden ist
wenn uns das gelände ansehen so erkennen
wir dass erstens die ukrainische seite
sich offensichtlich in mehreren tief
gestaffelten verteidigungslinien
eingerichtet hat das heißt man geht
davon aus dass zb im kessel selber es
zumindest drei
verteidigungslinien gibt es die kurse
hier die russische seite aufhalten der
nächste faktor des geländes der
einschränkungen für die russische seite
ist ist der bewuchs oder auch die
struktur des geländes man erkennt es
hier sehr gut die russen haben also eine
zeitlang gebraucht um aus diesem raum
der einerseits bewaldet ist
beziehungsweise auch von einem fluss
durchflossen wird entsprechend heraus
treten zu können um dann quasi die
nördliche zange zu entwickeln eine
situation die auch im westen wo es aber
ganz klar die nächste starke
verteidigungslinie darstellt
als zweiter faktor sehen wir uns nun die
kräfte an und die kräfte
gegenüberstellung auf diese skizze kann
man erkennen dass er von klinischer
seite insgesamt 27 brigade äquivalente
bereitgestellt sind eine brigade der
ukrainischen streitkräfte hat in etwa
drei bataillonen das heißt wir reden von
insgesamt 81 bataillonen die sich hier
befinden auf der russischen seite gehen
die westlichen medien aber auch die
westliche nachrichtendienste davon aus
dass wir 93 bataillons taktische gruppe
im einsatz haben das heißt wir haben ein
verhältnis und 81 zu 93 wenn wir uns die
situation in dem sich möglichen kessler
ansehen dann sehen wir das verhältnis
von 48 bataillonen zu 68 patronen das
heißt das verhältnis das der angreifer
braucht nämlich quasi eins zu vier wird
von russischer seite nicht erfüllt denn
bei näherer betrachtung stellt man fest
dass die kräfte in etwa gleich sind bzw
die ukrainische seite auch den vorteil
hat dass ihre kräfte massiv eingegangen
sind
ein weiterer faktor spielt die zeit um
eine operation rasch und zielgerichtet
entwickeln zu können ist es ganz
entscheidend schnell zu agieren hier war
das problem der russen wenn sie sich
jetzt zurück erinnern an das gelände
passieren beginnzeit brauchten um aus
dem schwierigen gelände heraus treten zu
können um sich bereit zu stellen für
diesen angriff der vorgesehen war in
richtung süden wir können das hier am
beispiel von ist jung ist jetzt eine
kleine stadt die eingebettet ist
zwischen zwei schwierigen gelände teilen
die vor allem bewaldet sind und
zusätzlich noch der herausforderung hat
das einfluss dass wir es getan jetzt
durch diesen raum fließen das heißt die
ukrainische verteidigung hat sich an
dieses gelände angelehnt der erste
angriff der russin wurde abgewehrt es
hat also zwei sein gedauert bis dann die
russische seite durch dieses bewaldete
gebiet das eigentlich für den einsatz
von mechanisierten griffen nicht
geeignet ist um fassen konnte zwei
motoren brücken gelegt hat und dann von
hier aus weiter angetreten ist und es
tatsächlich geschafft hat die
ukrainische seite in der tiefe zu
umfassen und zu zerschlagen erst dann
wenn die voraussetzungen geschaffen sich
hier bereitzustellen für einen weiteren
angriff richtung süden das hat aber
natürlich zeit gekostet die in der
operationsführung gefehlt hat
nach der um fassung und dem leben der
proton brücken weiß möglich kräftig weil
sie über den fluss in einen
bereitstellungsraum zu bringen dazu
haben natürlich einerseits kampfpanzer
aber auch motorisierte elemente gezählt
aber natürlich auch die artillerie
solches diese bereitstellungsraum wurde
erweitert und man hat begonnen dann
entsprechend diesen angriff richtung
süden durchzuführen
der nächste faktor entscheidend ist ist
information die russische seite versucht
laufen sich ein lagebild über den
einsatz der chemischen kräfte zu
schaffen dazu werden vor allem drohnen
eigentlich es gelingt den ukrainischen
kräften immer wieder diese drohnen
abzuschießen wie zum beispiel hier
dieses system rang zehn was ist für die
russen schwierig macht sich tatsächlich
ein lagebild zu verschaffen und vor
allem die eigene kampf unterstützung
also der artillerie zielgerichtet
einzusetzen
besonders das lager bietest du die
russische seite denn der einsatz der
kräfte orientiert sich natürlich an der
positionierung der ukrainischen
streitkräfte wir sehen hier ein beispiel
einer ukrainischen stellung einmal mit
vorgelagerten schützen geben aber auch
hier in der geländekante mit
zusätzlicher schützen geben und auch
unterständen die russische seite
versucht nun diese position aufzuklären
und die zieht mit artillerie zu
beschießen die relativ leicht
magnetischen kräfte hingegen können bei
einem vorstoßen der russischen kräfte
mit zum beispiel panzer waffen relativ
reicht die russische seite schwer
treffen und abnutzen das heißt man
erkennt dass die ukrainische seite die
letzten jahre genutzt hat sich hier
massiv ein zugaben zusätzlich ist es so
dass es immer wieder zur sogenannten
mobilen verteidigung kommt das heißt vor
einem artillerie schlag versuchen die
ukraine auszuweichen oder in die
unterstände zu gehen und dann erst beim
antreten der russen die stellungen wider
zu beziehen und entsprechend eine abwehr
erfolg zu erzielen
die russen versuchen dieser taktik der
ukraine entgegenzuwirken indem sie
massive artillerie einsetzten einerseits
haben wir immer öfters den einsatz
dieser der moralischen raketenwerfer vom
typ ts 1 oder theorie sein soll war aber
auch von mehrfach raketen vom typ ibm 30
oder bm 27 nach diesen vorbereiteten
artilleriefeuer erst dann wird versucht
was sie mit mechanisierten kräften
unterstützung infanterie langsam
vorzumarschieren hat aber natürlich die
herausforderung dass die überlebenden
kräfte der ukrainischen seite mit diesem
panzer bewachen den russen immer wieder
verluste beibringen können
wir wissen auch dass die ukrainische
seite vermutlich in der tiefe kräfte
bereit gestellt hat wenn die russische
seite tatsächlich einen durchbruch
erzielen sollte um diesen durchbruch
anzugreifen also die nördliche oder die
südliche zange dazu brauchen sie
einerseits panzer aber auch
schützenpanzer
beziehungsweise auch andererseits die
fähigkeit diese kräfte einen eingriff
durchführen zu lassen darum ist die
lieferung von diesen gepaart panzer und
so wichtig denn nur durch den einsatz
der gepard ganze würde es gelingen die
russische seite daran zu hindern diesen
angriffe aufzuhalten denn der vorteil
der russischen seite ist sie haben die
luftüberlegenheit im dom bass das heißt
sie erleiden zwar immer wieder verluste
aber sie können wo sie möchten mit ihren
kampfflugzeugen und kampfhubschraubern
zu schlagen das heißt ein derartiger
gegenangriff der ukrainische seite kann
nur funktionieren wenn es gelingt die
russische seite daran zu hindern ihn zu
zerschlagen auf russischer seite werden
eingesetzt erdkampfflugzeuge vom typ su
aber auch kampfhubschrauber das heißt
durch die mitgeführten flow system mit
ukrainischen seite wäre es möglich diese
so zu neutralisieren dass dieser
ukrainische gegenangriff tatsächlich
einen raum gewinnen kann
die frage ist nun wenn wir uns diese
situation ansehen wie wird die situation
sich in den nächsten wochen weiter
entwickeln bzw wer entscheidet
möglicherweise diese schlacht für sich
es gibt einige faktoren die eine
wichtige rolle spielen ich habe schon
betont die bedeutung von artillerie wir
haben auf der einen seite auf der
russischen seite der massive artillerie
ansatz den man jetzt von ukrainischer
seite versucht entgegenzuwirken und dann
erkennt dass gerade die
waffenlieferungen von westlicher seite
auf das jetzt das beispiel gezogene
geschütze sind wie aus den usa oder auch
motorisierte einheiten auf rädern oder
selbst so lafette genau in diese
richtung zielt also artillerie systeme
der ukraine zur verfügung zu stellen und
die russische nationale systeme
auszuschalten
der zweite faktor der hier ganz
wesentlich ist dass wir im prinzip auf
beiden seiten diesen versuch erkennen
können nämlich auch die russische seite
versucht durch das heranführen von
zusätzlichen aktiven systemen einerseits
mehrfach raketenwerfern aber auch
schwerer belagerung artillerie- wie zum
beispiel von diesen 203 mm geschützen
versucht die ukrainische seite suchte
sie für abzunutzen in der hoffnung sie
so abzunutzen dass sie bevor sie die
westlichen waffensysteme eintreffen
einer entsprechenden angriff durchführen
kann dadurch bricht
es gibt natürlich noch andere faktoren
eine rolle spielen zum beispiel wenn es
der russischen seite tatsächlich
gelingen sollte zum beispiel im norden
bistum durchzubrechen könnte sein dass
wir den bereits angekündigten einsatz
von kamikaze drohen sehen der dann
diesen vorstoß der russische seite ein
ende setzt
wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass die
russische seite versucht ist zu
unterbinden das heißt sie konzentriert
sich nicht nur auf den preis sondern
versucht vor allem in der tiefe des
landes die waffenlieferungen in den
obersten unterbrechen sie setzt dabei
ihre luftstreitkräfte ein wie zb diese
mit 31 mit dieser mit diesem kind
schalen hyperschall flugkörper
oder auch unterschiedlichste systeme
ballistische raketen aber auch von
cruise missiles die wir täglich seit dem
24 februar im einsatz sehen ein guter
bei ein gutes beispiel für diese absicht
haben in den letzten zehn tagen gesehen
immer wieder haupt die russische seite
versucht in der tiefe des landes ganz
gezielt vor allem die struktur der
eisenbahn einrichtungen zu treffen indem
sie die umspannwerke und trafostation an
der seite angegriffen haben in der
hoffnung auf grund des nicht mehr
verfügbaren elektrifizierten netzes eine
reduktion der transporte zu erfüllen bei
jugendlichen seite dadurch dass ihre
elektro loks nicht mehr benutzen kann
auch dieselloks zurückgreifen muss
interessant waren vor allem die angriffe
in den letzten tagen wo zum beispiel
auch bei einem tunnel in den beskiden
ganz gezielt versucht worden ist die
dortige trafostation für die versorgung
zu unterbrechen das heißt man kann also
hier klar erkennen die absichten russen
hier entsprechend durch interaction zu
verhindern dass diese westlichen
waffensysteme rechtzeitig zur schlacht
im dom bass eintreffen
nach dieser lage darstellung möchte ich
kurz einen blick in die vergangenheit
werfen und versuchen anhand eines
historischen beispiele ist einen
rückschluss darauf zu lassen wie diese
situation sich möglicherweise in den
nächsten tagen und wochen weiter
entwickeln kann tatsächlich ist es so
dass im selben raum 19 43 es bereits zu
einer kissenschlacht gekommen ist nehme
ich die berühmte schlacht vom kurs das
deutsche unternehmen sieht der delle das
nördlich von charkiw stattgefunden hat
hier war es so dass die sowjetische
seite einen front verbogen richtung
westen gehalten hat und die deutsche
seite versucht hat in einer
zangenbewegung aus dem norden und aus
dem süden dieses politische kräfte
dispositiv einzukesseln die situation
heute ist ja ähnlich südlich von charkiw
haben wir ebenfalls einen front diesmal
der ukrainischen seite in richtung osten
und die russische seite versucht in zwei
zangen bewegungen aus dem norden und aus
dem süden dieses ukrainische kräfte die
es positiv einzukesseln
wenn wir uns den ausgang der schlacht
von kursk 1943 ansehen so sind sich die
historiker einig dass es im wesentlichen
drei faktoren waren die diese schlacht
für die sowjetische seite entschieden
haben der erste faktor war dass die
sowjetische seite sehr genau wusste wo
und zu welcher zeit diese deutschen
angriffe stattfinden werden man nimmt an
aufgrund der entschlüsselung einer
deutschen schritt vier maschinen vom typ
enigma der zweite faktor war dass die
politische seite sich monatelang sehr
exakt auf diesen angriff vorbereitet hat
und verteidigungsstellungen in der tiefe
vor allem in den flanken errichtet hat
zur abwehr des deutschen angriffes unter
dritte faktor war die verbissenheit der
sowjetischen soldaten beim kampf und bzw
bei der abwehr dieser deutschen angriffe
und am ende musste die deutsche seite
diese beiden zahlen bewegungen abbrechen
und die sowjetische seite konnte die
schlacht zu sich entscheiden wenn wir
diese situation in den bars übertragen
so sehen wir dass diese drei faktoren
offensichtlich auch hier zur anwendung
kommen der erste faktor ist dass
offensichtlich die ukrainische seite
sehr genau bescheid weiß über die art
und weise der russischen angriffe der
zweite faktor ist das jüdische seite
sich sogar jahrelang vorbereitet hat und
tief gestaffelte verteidigungsstellungen
eingerichtet hat in erwartung des
russischen angriffes und der dritte
faktor unbestritten seit beginn der
angriffe auf die ukraine die
verbissenheit der ukrainischen soldaten
die quasi jeden meter boden verteidigen
mit der absicht die russische seite so
abzunutzen dass dieser angriff
schlussendlich scheitert und nicht den
erfolg bringt den sich die russische
seite erwartet zum schluss möchte ich
ihnen diese videosequenz und dieses
standbild aus dieser sequenz zeigen sie
erkennen hier die situation der
ukrainischen soldaten im drum bass wir
sehen eine schützengraben linie die sich
quasi von nord bis süd zieht wir kennen
gerade von den einschlägen der
russischen artillerie in den letzten
tagen beziehungsweise sehen wir hier
auch gerade den einschlag eines die liga
hatte die ukrainische soldaten die wir
hier erkennen können versuchen war sie
diesen ein schlägen auszuweichen indem
sie in den schützengräben schutz suchen
dieses bild soll ihnen zeigen dass wir
eine situation haben die sehr an den
ersten weltkrieg erinnert werden 1916
also einen stellungskrieg wo beide
seiten versucht haben durch den massiven
einsatz von artillerie sich abzunutzen
die russische seite versucht die
stellungen der ukraine zu zerschlagen um
angreifen zu können
die ukrainische seite versucht die
russen so abzunutzen dass dieser angriff
nicht mehr möglich ist damit bin ich am
ende meiner ausführungen und wie gesagt
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal